[Music]
uh if you guys
uh remember this case from when it first
happened then this is quite the
development you'll be happy to uh find
out about an orange county woman
who was allegedly kidnapped while
jogging in 2016
by two hispanic women who held her for
22 days broke her nose branded her arm
and shaved her head whoa
is now found to have made the whole
thing up oh
whoa what was what was this uh was it a
fake hate crime story or was it like
what's happening she did a juicy smell
yet yeah was it a juicy sommelier
juicy smoothie i don't know if this is
better or worse she she basically did it
to spend time with her ex
she's married
oh my god
kind of i kind of i kind of give credit
to them
where was this irvine
it's uh orange county but you still have
to brand yourself though right dude
that's crazy why does she have to be
like two mexican girls dated to me
that's very orange county [ __ ] dude
give asians some credit man there's
hardcore asians out there you're gonna
be like two [ __ ] abg's from
westminster [ __ ] me up
they never look at us that way
we need to rebrand this [ __ ]
dude can we just take it away from other
people like i want some hardcore asians
back dude yeah so uh
what else did she if she did it herself
then uh other than the branding did she
also like break something of hers broke
her nose right broke her nose she she
basically
was covered in like she would have been
beaten oh my what the [ __ ] did she get
help from her ex but if she made it up
does that mean her ex just beat her up
well they staged the whole thing so yeah
man i guess it was her ex yeah so she
was on a [ __ ] spree because she missed
that dick right
they might all just be [ __ ] bruises
every day right you're right i don't
think of that you got a binge you gotta
been a little bit of a broken nose yeah
shaved head on the last day she's like
oh i lost track of time we've been
[ __ ] every day it's really awful
because i remembered like seeing this
when it happened and like and there was
in the community there was a really big
fear of like oh there must be some like
mexican like gang
or something like that's so [ __ ] for
mexico she couldn't just say two people
kidnapped me but then they're gonna ask
for description you know
ethnically ambiguous assailants and she
spent a lot of time with him yeah she's
a mother she wouldn't know that's true
why couldn't she just use another
culture that no one suspects two indian
chicks
there's indians in the oc though
yeah indians don't yeah they're not
known what's a safe culture
she's hispanic
she's white she's white even worse you
gotta do mixed race that's what you
gotta do two estonians
estonians
one estonian one no one gets hurt yeah
you know it's like two lithuanians just
came up and picked up me out man
the writing she's
[Laughter]
she's cute oh it's okay mother of two
these this is [ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ]
i hate you this is the police sketch of
the two women she fabricated damn
they did a good job that was really
detailed like one of them had a bandana
look at her eyebrows look how she
described the eyebrows one of them
looked like jennifer lopez
oh my god that just looks like danny
trejo
daddy
the other one was jennifer lopez he was
like machete but he was a chick though
is there a photo of her when um after
she was like beat up and branded and
stuff yeah yeah i know right i want to
see that i i couldn't find anything like
that cause she's cute there but after
she gets all [ __ ] up i did oh [ __ ]
dude
yeah this is her after she uh
did she get back with her head shake
[ __ ] connor
yeah but um
yeah so basically that uh she went for a
jog and they did get that on camera they
were like okay so she was running and
this is back when they thought she was
legit kidnapped uh they got the video of
her on her jog and then uh the the
husband when when he found out she was
missing to find my iphone they go to the
location of the phone and it's like it's
sitting down the screen's not cracked
the earbuds are like wrapped around all
neatly like it was just placed so that
was like the first like don't worry
about the flag don't hurt your phone
like oh there's no because the first
thing i always look for during
kidnappings is signed of a struggle
right that's like the first thing didn't
get that
i
and then uh so what happened was after
she finally turned up like 22 days later
all messed up and everything they did
some like dna testing on her body and
that's when they found the
inconsistencies or they they found the
dna of like a different guy
oh
his [ __ ] was all up on her dude oh [ __ ]
oh you should have gotta cut that [ __ ]
dude
so dna man that freaking exonerates
mexicans everywhere even ones that don't
exist yeah because they're like all i
see
is [ __ ] a romanian man's comic
media man's come with
he's probably romanian
the x
how do you know i'm just going to say
widow's peak yeah these are pictures
do they get back together oh yeah and
then here's another thing that um that
was sort of like a suspicion
is um when they when the details weren't
really adding up and they couldn't find
the suspects and things you know of
course like all good detectives can be
like
she's probably making it up they
discovered she had a history of
self-harm
uh they saw in her files that when she
was like younger she was like harming
herself and saying her parents were
doing it and then her parents were like
asking the police like what do we do
because she's doing this so it's kind of
like a trend thing with her
and this might just be her magnum opus
you know maybe her description
was like
too [ __ ] trophy
like maybe her description of mexican
girls was like two-two trophy like she
was like the
the most
yeah it was like yeah and then they were
like hey what's up [ __ ] [ __ ] vato
and i was like i'm not avatar
or like yeah
and then the the mexican cop was like
that's not even spanish dude
like yeah like trolls don't speak like
that yeah or he's like that's my sister
that sounds like my sister yeah when she
they were asking for a description she
basically said they look just like the
people on the cover of hood rats the
movie okay there you go
see
she goes have you ever seen blood and
blood out well it was like the girls
from that movie
you guys seen blood blowout that
that that's who got me and shaved my
head
but yeah it's uh it's crazy because that
that that this is barely coming out now
that this was years ago that she was
kidnapping everything so what happens to
her does she get charged among other
charges that are yet to um i mean
one thing she has to do for sure is she
has to pay back 30 000 to the um state
for like when you get kidnapped and
things happen to you the state pays for
some recovery things like therapy or
like
she basically soaked all that up
so she's got to pay 30k back um
and then of course she should get
charged for the crimes that she charged
yeah and get her nose re-broken because
she beat herself up and she kidnapped
herself assault yeah so she should be
charged with the crimes like kidnapping
assault you know yeah like x amount of
days whatever whatever every charge
would have been to those two hispanic
women that she described oh dude you're
gonna love this so they were asking her
about her uh when she was in uh
captivity and she said the abductors fed
fed me once a day maybe rice or
tortillas god damn it god damn it well
that makes sense if you're sticking to
your story
no you gotta sell it they give you rice
and tortillas so just cause they're
mexican they can't get any other food
they played mariachi music very loudly
by the way they tortured me i couldn't
tell if it was actually a mariachi band
or not i was smelling fabuloso in the
house what do you what would asian
kidnappers feed you if they [ __ ] rice
and egg rolls dude
[Laughter]
wontons
it'll be like crab rangoons or some [ __ ]
orange chicken she was only feeding me
crab bread
cream cheese ranch and fortune cookies
at the end of every meal i got fortune
cookies top ramen it was horrible they
gave me nothing but filipino the
philadelphia rules dude and that they
would read my fortunes after i know
sushi
only sushi
the haitian kidnappers [ __ ] gold
today this is yotocha
they crack over a torture cookie and
they have a [ __ ]
water boating
or every day it's like you think you're
gonna get out but the fortune always
says not today
oh one more day
one more day but maybe sometime soon
welcome to the panda of tara keeps you
optimistic yeah so they were they were
lucky numbers on the back they were
mostly like uh
i mean the community just got enraged
because [ __ ] that right so what's gonna
happen to her she's just facing charges
i don't know yet what will happen but
she should eat rice's tortillas for 22
days straight but dude the crazy thing
is like she should get community service
so they said that like even though they
already found out that the [ __ ] was like
falsified and like fraud they were still
like um
you know like interviewing her maybe
they were deposing her but like they uh
they said she was still sticking to her
story years later
even though they're like so she believes
it's you or with your ex we already got
that [ __ ] all that's all laid out
there's a video he's confessed saying
she's gotten violent sympathy for so
long clearly that she's just addicted to
it yeah do you do you feel like people
like this crazy lie about crimes they
should be punished pretty hard
i think so because not only is it just
[ __ ] up the uh you know the the
resources for the cops and all that yeah
but it's tearing up communities yeah i
guarantee you this [ __ ] brought tension
between white and hispanics and orange
county because then you know like
there's already kkk in [ __ ] orange
county and they're like you see goddamn
mexicans they gotta get out here they're
[ __ ] raping our children and that's
the [ __ ] they're looking for honestly
and it's like can you imagine how many
mexican women that maybe look somehow
looked like that uh sketch
[ __ ] yeah those two girls look like
every home girl i had in [ __ ] junior
high
and high school
that watch blood and blood out
that's all they do
watch blood and blood and tortillas and
rice
but yeah
there was also a gofundme to like find
her the husband did and they raised 50k
uh i hope they're still together oh yeah
what's going on with the husband
uh he does he get to keep that
i don't know if they if they're so they
they ended up moving to like a small
town together to like get away from like
i guess the threat of being re-kidnapped
oh um and i guess like who ride that
story he was behind her on the story
this whole way i don't even know if he's
like he might be that cocked oh wow god
bro what about the ex-boyfriend i want
to follow up with this guy does he go to
jail i want to hang out with him
i don't know if he did anything you
stayed with her he's an accessories
corroborating her [ __ ] story yeah
unless he or he beat her unless he just
says he didn't know that that was what
she was planning like he was just along
for the ride because you could probably
claim a lot of [ __ ] wouldn't you hear
about it after and be like
wait a minute that's what i did that
didn't happen that's what the brand was
for yeah
he goes i thought she was shaving her
head for sexual reasons
you